hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
tcr sequencing and bcr sequencing
solutions
applications to clinical research
projects
today's webinar will be presented to you
by dr brian
o'connor associate professor and
scientific director of genomics
at national jewish health i'm christy
jewell of roberts
and i'll be moderating today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab routes and
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please click on the thermo fisher logo
on the left side of your screen
before we begin i would like to
encourage you to get the most out of
today's webinar
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want
during the presentation simply type them
into the ask a question box on the left
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or use that ask a
question box
on the left today's presentation is
educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
following this presentation
those credits can be obtained by
clicking on the
continuing education credits tab at the
top right of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr brian o'connor
dr o'connor is an associate professor
and scientific director of genomics
at national jewish health in the center
for genes environment and health
his work focuses on understanding how
epigenetic mechanisms regulate
the decision processes governing immune
cell activity
in the context of disease for a complete
biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
welcome dr o'connor you may now begin
your presentation
okay thank you for that introduction um
my name is brian o'connor i am the
associate professor
at national jewish health and i've been
the scientific director of a genomics
facility for a couple years now
our facility has a lot of experience
working with thermo fisher
and their ion ampliseq products
and today what i'm going to be talking
about is their tcrc and bcr seek
solutions
specifically in the context of how you
can use these tools
for clinical research projects
so national jewish health we have a lot
of experience looking at tcr
many of the audience may know of tip
america and her husband john kepler
they've been looking at t cells and
specifically t cell receptors for quite
a long time
and using nection sequencing approaches
pip has been
looking at tcr usage in t-cell
populations using next-gen sequencing
for example
before 2013 she was using the 454
platform
around 2013 working with thermo fisher
we
came up with a home brew system to look
at tcr sequencing using
the ion approach and in 2019 thermal
launched their kit-based solutions for
tcr vcr sequencing
we became a preferred academic partner
of thermo fisher for
tcr and vcr sequencing so you have a
long history
of using ion ampliseq and ion approaches
for different questions at national
jewish
so for today's talk what i'm going to be
giving you is a brief overview of
the tcr sequencing and vcr sequencing
solutions that
thermo fisher provides and then i want
to give you
a brief overview of how you can apply
these tools
to specific kinds of questions in
inflammatory diseases
for clinical research so i'm going to
give you two different
brief overviews of case studies one
dealing with a disease called
sarcoidosis and another one
called cystic fibrosis and of course
today
uh given everything that's happening in
the world would be remiss if we didn't
briefly discuss
uh cov2 applications for tcr vcr
sequencing as well so
talk briefly about that there's obvious
examples of how to use tcr sequencing
and vcr sequencing and immunobiology
for things like animal models and we'll
use
a future webinar to discuss those
applications
so a brief overview of tcr and bcr
sequencing and why you might do it
um so these are some slides that thermo
fishery was good enough to provide me
with
so when thinking about the adaptive
immune system there's really
two major cell types t cells and b cells
and one of the things that makes t cells
and b cells special is this idea of
combinatorial diversity
so you have v d and j genes
that recombine at a dna level these
recombination events
lead to unique combinations that when
translated into proteins become the b
cell receptor and the t
cell receptor that are expressed on the
cell surface of b cells and t
cells the bcr and tcr
enable b cells and t cells to see
antigens to recognize pathogens
and when b cells and t cells recognize
these pathogens they undergo
rapid proliferation in a process called
coral expansion
this allows the immune system to deal
with an invading pathogen or deal with
some
some antigens in this process that
unique combination of vdj
gets amplified within the cellular
population
so in one way in thinking about this the
clonal expansion process
identifies a antigen response
and that anagen response is due to that
unique gene sequence
so if you had a way to see that unique
gene sequence to read it
and to track it it would enable you to
track the immune response and to
identify an ongoing
immune response so in terms of clinical
research
when thinking about acute responses or
chronic
diseases understanding when an immune
response is occurring and what kind of
an immune response is occurring
becomes a really powerful tool so
sequencing the unique combination of ddj
becomes a really great way to track an
immune response
historically there's been lots of
different methods to look
at tcrs and bcrs within t cells and b
cells
so people have used things like five
prime race or multiplex pcr
these methods have advantages and
disadvantages
in the context of five prime race one of
it's it's a great technique but it's not
very scalable you can't really apply to
lots of different
samples or at least it's very difficult
to do that
for multiplex pcr you can look at lots
of different variable
regions at the same time but because of
the differential combinations of lots of
different prime repairs you start to get
into some issues with
loss of certain transcripts so they have
their advantages and disadvantages
ion ampliseq provides a really great
solution to some of these advantages and
disadvantages essentially this is a
combination of pcr
and nextgen sequencing so use pcr to
target the region that you're interested
in in this case the t
cell receptor genes or the b cell
receptor genes
those targets are amplified and then
those amplicons are made into a next-gen
sequencing library
and the sequencing platform then reads
off
those transcripts amplifying that that
signal so you can read it
pretty easily
in terms of the sequencing platform
thermofisher has
a flexible system they have different
kinds of
sequencers in terms of their capacity
going from an s5
to an s5 plus to an s5 prime national
jewish health we use an s5 prime all the
time
and they also have different size chips
where your samples
are loaded onto the sequencing platform
and the chips also come in different
sizes so again you have that flexibility
you can
put different kinds of samples on or
different numbers of samples
and really i think one of the huge
advantages of this entire system is not
just the combination
of the way the assay works this
combination of pcr and ngs
but it's also the analysis software on
the back end it really
um at least for us has become a game
changer so
thermo fisher's made it very easy for
researchers to
analyze their own data through this
this software suite this this suite of
tools
that is easily accessible in the cloud
so it's called
their iron reporter software so they
have lots of different tools on there
you can apply it in lots of different
contexts not just immunology but they
have things for
for exomes and then genomics we've used
a lot of these tools in our research
here at national jewish
and specifically in the context of tcr
and vcr repertoires
a lot of this types of questions or
types of analysis that you might want to
do
whether it's just looking at the vdj
sequences or trying to track coral
expansions
or in the context of t cells looking at
convergence of different t cell
receptors
or in the context of b cells looking at
somatic mutation analysis
or lineage analysis all this is really
easily done
on the ion reporter system it's very
intuitive very easy to use
i have a pc in immunology i do not have
formal training in bioinformatics or
computational biology
and for me to to be able to go on to the
system and use it and
create graphs that are publication
quality or able to stick into a grant
it really has has been a game changer
for us
this assay can use either dna or rna as
an input there's
advantage and disadvantage to both if
you
are a researcher that has a lot of ffpe
type samples
where you know the material is going to
be fragmented dna is probably the way to
go for that
and there's there's both a long ring and
a short new version of this assay so
the short read version is probably the
way to go on the other hand
if you are dealing with a specialized
cell type where you know you're not
going to have a lot of
a lot of cells or the ability to isolate
a lot of cells rna is going to be the
way to go
again because of that expression is
going to amplify the signal so
there's reasons to use either dna or rna
and we can discuss we can help
help discuss which one to go
for specific projects
and then again because tcr and vcr
sequencing
becomes a great tool a great window into
an immune response
when thinking about clinical research it
allows you to ask lots of different
questions
so you in terms of her malignancies or
autoimmunity or vaccine
immunology it allows you to think about
what's happening within the immune
response and to track that response
over time bulk sequencing
which is what we're talking about here
versus single cell
sequencing answers different kinds of
questions
but really when thinking about clinical
research settings where you
are going to have to look at lots of um
different types of samples and different
numbers of samples
bulk sequencing becomes a lot easier
just in terms of um
price and and the practical ability to
apply it to to lots of samples
so there really are a lot of different
available tools
within the within the ampliseq family
and so
we at national jewish have used a lot of
these products and have had
really good experiences with with with a
lot of them so i encourage
anybody to look into all of the
different possibilities
that therma has provided
so with that i want to i want to start
talking about
the different applications or different
kinds of questions you can
ask with tcr sequencing and bcr
sequencing i'm going to give you two
different case studies that
we've we've been performing here at
national jewish
two different research stories so this
first story is a project that i've been
involved with lisa meyer who's an md at
national jewish health
she's a specialist in the area of
sarcoidosis
and we've been looking at the role of t
cells
in the context of this disease for a
number of years now
so sarcoidosis is uh an inflammatory
chronic disease
it's one of the hallmarks of this
disease are these granuloma formations
which are
groups of of immune cells like
macrophages and t cells and diesels that
come together
and form this inflammatory component one
of the
issues with sarcoidosis when thinking
about how do we understand it
it's really a disease of unknown
etiology so we don't really understand
why this disease starts
different kinds of infectious agents or
organic particles or inorganic
material can are thought to contribute
to
inflammatory reactions that become
chronic over time
there's a variable disease course so we
know that
cd4 positive t cells are involved in
this disease
because we see them in inflammatory
spaces
but from one um one example to another
there's really a variable disease course
and so we have a tough time
understanding why why different
inflammatory situations occur
and of course because there's a variable
disease course there's also a variable
progression so in some some instances we
get remission in some instances we get
progression and progression leads to
this fibrotic type of reaction that
occurs within the lungs
leading to to worsening lung function
to be really one of the key things that
we need to understand is what's
happening in the context of
this immune response tracking immune
response and understanding the
programming that's occurring
so with lisa and others
at other institutions we've been
tracking t cells in the context of
sarcoidosis for
for a while now and some of this work
was supported by nrl1 from
nhlbi
so our main one of the main things that
we're trying to understand in this
context is when you think about chronic
diseases
mature t cells that can exist in your
body for a long period of time
in the context of these chronic
inflammatory conditions
are going to experience lots of signals
signals that are derived either from the
disease state
from the microenvironment from genetic
programming
and all of this comes together in the
context of this huge combinatorial
diversity
in the context of specific t-cell
receptors um
and again also in the context of b-cells
or b-cell receptors
and over time this can lead to changes
in the population of t-cells or b-cells
and so what we'd like to understand is
how does that molecular program that's
occurring
contribute to the pathogenic activity of
the immune response
in the case of sarcoidosis we know that
th1 type of activities and cb4 positive
t
cells contributes to disease but we'd
also like to understand
what are the molecular programs that
might drive more t regulatory cells
in the same component in the same
population of cd4 positive t cells
that be more protective so if we can
understand that decision process and
those signals
that are involved in driving different
types of
t cell function we could then understand
better what's happening in this disease
so one of the first things we were able
to do was to take cd4 positive t cells
derived from peripheral blood cells
and perform rna-seq so what you're
seeing here
is unsupervised clustering of
differentially expressed genes comparing
sarcoidosis samples versus
normal healthy samples so the
sarcoidosis samples are denoted in the
red bar
and the normal samples in the blue bar
so one of the gratifying things that we
first saw at this really global level
is that indeed the normal samples
cluster separately from the sarcoidosis
samples at a transcriptional level
we've formed ipa pathway analysis we're
able to identify
immune pathways that are specific
to sarcoidosis samples versus control
samples
and again what we saw were some of these
different t cell functions that were
popping out so th1 and teach two
activation pathways or teach too
specific or teach one specific pathways
so it was telling us that in the context
of sarcoidosis the cd4 positive t
cell activity and function is being
differentially regulated
and so next we wanted to ask the
question well if we
think about sarcoidosis and different
disease phenotypes or different types of
disease
in terms of severity or the phenotype of
what's happening
in those different types of sarcoidosis
we wanted to understand could we see rna
signatures that distinguish those
different disease phenotypes
so here what you're seeing again is
unsupervised clustering of
differentially expressed genes from
rna-seq
of cd4 positive t cells from the
peripheral blood
and we do again see differential
of different phenotypes so the
least severe phenotype sarc
0 is in blue an inflamma more
inflammatory
type of sarcoidosis sarc2 is in red
and then stark 3 is a little bit more of
a fibrotic type of disease
and that's denoted in green so each of
the different phenotypes are
differentially clustering
and the bottom line here is when we
looked at the different genes that are
hallmarking or denoting
the different types of phenotypes
we were starting to see the emergence of
specific functions at least at a
transcriptional level
so when thinking globally about
sarcoidosis versus wild type we started
with cth1 versus th17
we started to delve deeper into the
specific disease phenotypes we started
to see the emergence of functions like
th2
or tfh and so this led us to really
come to an understanding that there are
different t-cell programs that are being
regulated
depending on the different disease
phenotypes
so this led us to really think about
okay what is happening within the immune
system there seems to be differential
regulation
occurring
and so this really leads into then
tcr sequencing what we were looking for
was some biomarker some handle on trying
to understand
why you get different disease phenotypes
why disease progresses
um variably from from one
instance versus another and so what we
wanted to ask the question was within
the cd4 positive
cell compartment if we use tcr
sequencing can we identify
different types of inflammation that are
occurring based on
different disease phenotypes
so i'm going to show you now is tcr
sequencing data
that we were able to get from
the ion ampliseq tool from
the sequencing kit and this is data that
was
directly generated from the
online tools that thermo provides so
what you're seeing here is a graph
for what is called evenness so
evenness is a idea that if you see
no clonal expansion across all of your
t-cell population
you expect the representation of your
tcr genes to be completely even meaning
that there's no bias in the usage of
those different genes
so even this on the top right you're
seeing a scale from zero to one
dark blue being the most even white
being the most uneven so blue basically
means
no clonal expansion white means chloral
expansion
the way this graph is laid out is along
the x-axis
on the top you see the different b genes
and on the y-axis
is the cdr3 blend so each
individual dot or circle represents a
specific
type or population of t cells
so for a stage 0 inactive
sarc sample basically this is a
sample and a phenotype that is mild
we are not seeing any of those white
circles meaning we're not really seeing
any examples of coal expansion and
clonal expansion in this case we would
interpret as an ongoing or active immune
response there's really no
signs of inflammation occurring for this
sample
if we move to a different phenotype
stage two
again we're not seeing any of these
white circles showing up so
again no example or no no evidence of
coral expansion
however if we move to a sample that has
been
characterized as being progressive stage
two progressive meaning
more severe disease or at least active
disease
now we are starting to see some of these
white circles showing up so this is
giving us confirmation that there is an
ongoing immune response happening
there's
evidence of clonal expansion within the
t-cell compartment occurring
and again this is another sample another
stage too progressive
sample so again clinically we're saying
that there is
ongoing disease and based on the tcr
analysis that we're able to see we're
seeing colon expansion occurring
as well
and so what we're able to conclude when
thinking about
the data coming off of this this tcr
analysis
is that progressive disease or disease
that we know that is
active does seem to be correlated with
coral expansion whereas
more stable disease does not show us any
examples of coal expansion
moreover when we compare tcr usages so
the vg's that are being
clonally expanded within different
different samples we're not seeing um
the same
genes being used meaning there doesn't
seem to be
overt evidence for
a single antigen or a single pathogen
driving
this coral expansion this is very
interesting
for us in the sarcoidosis world
because one of the major questions we
have with sarcoidosis again
is what drives this disease it is a
disease of unknown ideology
so there are ideas because it is a
granulomatous disease that there might
be
dominant pathogens that drive this
disease that we just haven't found yet
since we're not finding evidence for um
specific v genes being used they would
argue that this
disease is more complex and
environmentally driven
which is which is what a lot of us think
is happening with sarcoidosis so tcr
ion tcr sequencing we were able to apply
to sarcoidosis very easily
these grafts that i'm showing you were
very easy to generate
um it's very user friendly and it
gives us a tool that is very hard to do
in any other way for
for this amount of money to produce so
it gives us a tool where we can
we can pull out and identify and
visualize
specific clones within the entire t-cell
community
cell population so it it really has
helped us identify
active beliefs
so next i want to change
change up the the case study and so now
i'm going to tell you about
some work that mimi savager and lee
reinhardt have done at national jewish
health working with cystic fibrosis
so cystic fibrosis is a chronic um
respiratory disease
one of the issues with cf is that it is
characterized by repeated acute
pulmonary exacerbations
and these acute pulmonary exacerbations
um
over time lead to worsening lung
function and one of the primary reasons
is that
after the exacerbation a lot of the
patients do not return to baseline lung
function so their lung function
decreases
due to these exacerbations
so lee and nini came up with this
hypothesis that
t cells are getting differentially
programmed over time
and that within the memory tesla
compartment you're seeing a
dysfunction an immune dysfunction that
occurs
so that with these repeated pathogen
infections that drive a lot of these
pulmonary
exacerbations you're getting this
response
that does not clear so normally
pathogens are cleared efficiently and
because of the presence of memory
you get you get protection from from
subsequent infections
in the context of cf that doesn't occur
and so what they wanted to do is look at
memory cells
within the pbmcs and examine the
function of those cells and try to
understand
why it doesn't seem that patients
are protected and so they set out to do
this
this clinical research
one of the things that they initially
found
when looking at the memory t cells is
that they seem to have a functional bias
so here they took peripheral blood
derived memory t cells cd4 positive t
cells they stimulated them in the vitro
and then asked what are they doing
functionally
and they saw this th 17 and two bias
so th2 being identified by il4
production
and um and then they also looked dial-17
production
so they compared cf subjects who
were sick versus um
samples from uh cf um
well versus normal controls and
one of the things that you can i think
easily see is that there's a lot more
production of
il4 and a lot more production than mile
17 from the cd4 positive memory cells
derived from the cf6 subjects
versus versus the wealth subjects or
normal controls
so it really led them to this question
of okay what
you know what's happening um in the
context of
the of the inflammatory reaction
is there a specific set of t cells that
are driving this inflammation
that we know leads to decreasing lung
function over time
so they so they went ahead and did the
ion tcr sequencing and
this is another type of graph that you
can again easily produce
with the tools that thermal provides so
here what you're looking at are graphs
that
are now showing the combination unique
combinations of b and j genes that are
are used within individual clones and
again it's a similar readout so white
dots or white squares here are going to
show highly expanded clones
so with the cf subjects it's the the two
top graphs
you can see these white squares that are
showing
unique combinations of d and dnj genes
that are
that are highly expanded and
if you compare that with the normal
sample below
you'll see that the normal sample has a
lot of this white and gray
spread throughout whereas with the cf
samples
there's more defined regions of
of the white and the gray essentially
this is that same concept of evenness
in the normal sample you're seeing uh
more even distribution of these
of these different um use of the d and j
genes we're going to see if it seems to
be more restricted
so what mimi and lee observed and what
they concluded
that they were doing this kind of
analysis they were able to actually
identify dominant clones
that were tracking with cf inflammation
and when thinking about the amino acid
motifs that are coming from these
sequences they're wondering and starting
to ask questions about can you use that
to identify the bacterial antigens the
pathogens that
are driving this repeated chronic
inflammation in cf
when they compare the cf sequences
versus the
normals we were able to get a number a
greater number of motifs from the cf
samples
and when looking at those mates were
more shared motifs
in common in the cf samples versus the
normal samples
and the large majority of those samples
of those motifs that were
common in the sea of samples they didn't
even see any of those
in the normals so again they got really
excited by this because it's starting to
really give them a handle and a window
into
this specific t-cell clones the specific
t cells that seem to be involved in this
chronic inflammation that's occurring
that that drives down bond function
so some of the questions that they were
then able to ask and start to think
about
is do the expanded clone these specific
ones that they're seeing
in the cf samples do they translate to
greater inflammation and do they
translate
to a worsening lung function so they can
use things like
uh that are available like glyph to try
to identify shared motifs again this
idea of convergence are there t-cell
receptor genes that may be differential
genes but that seem to be identifying
the same energetic peptides
and so in doing that kind of analysis
and again working with the tools on ion
reporter
they can compare the motifs that are
that are being seen in the cf samples
versus the normal
subjects here they're doing principal
component analysis pca analysis
and again the cf subjects are are
are clustering separately from the
normal samples
and again doing the same analysis they
saw a lot of the same types of things
that they're seeing
that the cf motifs are shared and they
are not
within the cf samples but they're not
sharing with the normals
so moving forward they're really excited
to use this technology as a window into
the chronic inflammation that's
occurring in cf
to understand what's happening in the
memory t-cell compartment
and to potentially use this kind of
research to understand
are there specific types of bacterial
pathogens
that are driving the expansion of
specific t-cell clones
and if that's true then you can start to
think about ways to block that and maybe
you know stop this this chronic
inflammation that leads to
this worsening lung function over time
so i'd be remiss we'd all be remiss if
we didn't
think about sars kobe 2 um and
and how that's affecting all of our
research um
in anything that we do it's it's
uh something that at national jewish
health being a respiratory hustle that
we've had to think about very carefully
so i want to briefly go over
how we are beginning to apply ttr
sequencing and bcr sequencing to both of
these projects again as
examples of of how we're all going to
have to think about
this virus and how it impacts our
research studies
so in the context of sarcoidosis
again we know that it's a t cell driven
disease
and if we are thinking about the
molecular programming
that occurs in the context of these
chronic diseases we understand that
due to combinatorial diversity you can
have population
changes so different tcr's being used
within that
within the population of t cells
you have to start to wonder how does a
virus like cov2 potentially affect that
interaction
so the viral response is going to lead
to unique
disease signals specific clones are
going to be activated
how does all of that interact in the
context of an
ongoing chronic inflammatory disease so
this is something that we would love to
understand
and so i hope by now you've understood
that the tcr sequencing
and and also the bcr students and gives
you a really
nice tool to reach into the immune
system identify
i'll be able to see what's happening
within t cells and b cells
so we can use this tool
to start to understand how the presence
of
the virus may affect the function of t
cells in the function of d cells in
these diseases
so for sarcoidosis we want to use ttr
sequencing to identify
unique clonal expansions that are
happening in the presence of
the virus versus not we think that
again because this is viral infection
that there could be changes in the t
cell lineage so the function of the t
cells and again this
may have impacts on disease progression
so
we know that sarcoidosis is uh is
characterized by t1 activity we're also
seeing
examples of th17 or even th2 or tfh
so how does the virus impact on the
functional
aspects of of the t-cell population and
of course there's obvious questions
about how the virus may
may affect disease course over time
in the b-cell compartment when thinking
about bcr sequencing
there's ways to identify clinical
expansions and
of course anytime we're thinking about
viruses and vaccines or antibiotic
responses
be great to identify those coral
expansions the the b cells they're
responding
so we'd like to use bcr sequencing to
try to get a handle on that
we can also think about b-cell
maturation so
at least within sarcoidosis we know that
there's a presence of
these t-bet positive cells and
we'd like to understand are there
specific effects on
these kinds of b cells due to the
presence of the virus
and one of the things that we haven't
had time to discuss but again the bcr
sequencing tool from from thermal allows
you to look
at progression or maturation of b
cells so looking at plasma cells and
antibodies and isotype
changes or somatic hypermutation for
affinity maturation
allows you to track all of those things
again we expect that that will be
affected
by the presence of the virus so being
able to
apply these tools in the context
of sarcoidosis expecting that the virus
the presence of the virus should change
some of these things
having the ability to to look at the
t-cell compartment and the diesel
compartment
at that individual clone level
gives us a really powerful tool to
understand what's happening
in the immune system over the context of
this chronic disease
it's a very similar situation with cf so
again it's a chronic inflammatory
disease we know the immune system is
heavily involved
so what mimi and we have talked about
doing with tcr sequencing is
again to identify those novel call
expansions
since they are able to see some dominant
clones that seem to be associated with
cf
how do those clones change are there
going to be new clones that
that arise because of the presence of
virus
and what's happening to the clones that
they've already identified
they are interested again in this idea
of t-cell convergence
so what's happening to the overall
ability of
the t-cell population to see specific
types of
bacterial pathogens and antigens
associated with those bacterial
pathogens so does the presence of virus
change that or alter that
and of course the we all expect that the
presence of virus could have an impact
on disease course
the same thing in the b cell population
for for them as well since they're
really interested in trying to hone in
on
on bacterial pathogens and energies that
are driving
the ongoing inflammation that leads to
worsening lung function
being able to see the other side of the
adaptive immune system the b cell
and being able to track clones and
hopefully work backwards to to help
identify
specific antigens would enable them to
get a better handle
on what's happening with the presence of
virus
in sia
and so finally um i want to
talk about how tcr sequencing and bcr
sequencing at least as employed by
thermo fits in in the context of these
kinds of
mechanistic biomarker targeting studies
and clinical research
so one of the great things about this
assay is it's
essentially a bulk acid you can use it
with
t cells b cells you don't have to go
through fluoresceimetry
to identify a specific cell type or
specific subtype of your t cells or b
cells
unless of course you you want to do that
but it's still kind of high resolution
again because of this combination of pcr
and next-gen sequencing the pcr
is targeting um targeting the assay to
just look at the tcr or the bcr
sequences
so in comparison to something like
rna-seq if you were to try to do bcr
or tcr sequencing by bulk rna-seq you
would be wasting
a lot of not wasting but you'd have to
sequence at a really high level
to get your to your tcr bcr
sequences and even then your ability to
see
all the potential combinations would be
would be really low
pcr sequencing and vcr sequencing
because it's targeted
has that higher resolution for looking
at
the energy receptors and then of course
as many of you know
you can do bcr sequencing and tcr
sequencing with
single cell rna-seq approaches
the huge advantage of single-cell rna
sequencing approaches
over thermal's approach is that you get
to sequence
the entire receptor so for tcr you get
to look at both
tcr alpha and beta chains whereas
thermo's
approach only looks at the beta chain so
the huge advantage that
the single cell system has with the
approach is you get the entire
the entire energy receptor the the
drawbacks of single cell
is that as many of you know you're only
going to be able to look at a few
thousand cells at a time so you're not
really getting a
that big picture on the entire
population and of course it's a lot more
expensive
um than than ions uh ions approach
so there's there's pros and cons of both
which is why at national jewish we
really use them as companion assays
they're really ideal companion essays
for some uh for some of the questions
that we address
we're just trying to track coral
expansion so we don't need to have
both um the entire the entire image
receptor sequence we don't need the
alpha and the beta chain
so the ion platform works really well
for those questions we really do
want to have the entire receptor
sequenced
we'll do limited single cell rna
sequencing again because of limitations
with the cell numbers
and the cost to identify the
exact receptor that's being used and we
can follow those up with uh
with with tcr beta sequencing on a much
larger
number of samples to get a better idea
of what's happening
across a large population so there's
really
pros and cons of both approaches but
we've gotten a lot of use
out of thermo's approach
and then finally um at national jewish
health we are a service provider for
thermo fisher tcr bcr sequencing and
other ampliseq approaches
we know that a lot of a lot of different
institutions don't have
access currently to thermal ion
sequencers so if that's something that
that you need or you're interested in we
are a full service
uh solution for that here's some of our
our contact info you can contact
our generous facility directly at our
email address or phone number and
there's also a website where you can get
some more information
so i just want to finish up by thanking
the audience for
attending today and for your time again
i want to thank
thermo and labridge for for hosting this
and
i'd like to open it up to any questions
the audience might have
thank you dr o'connor for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for okay let's get started we have some
great questions already coming in
dr o'connor let's start with this one
how would you compare this method with
single cell sequencing
yeah that's a great question and that's
one that we um we get
all the time at at our genomics facility
so
researchers come to us with um you know
with different
questions that they want to address and
one of the first questions they have is
what's better should i be doing single
cell sequencing or should i be doing
um just this more bulk approach and it
really does come down to
the specific question that you have um
if
it's a question if it's an immunology
question where you really do want to
understand what the entire
energy receptor looks like then single
cell rna sequencing
is is the best way to go because you get
to have both chains
being sequenced however for
most of our our users um
we wind up going more with the thermo
approach and
and honestly one of the big reasons is
cost and the other reason
is the ability to look at a large
number of cells so you can literally
take
millions and millions of t cells out of
peripheral blood and
apply the thermo approach and get you
know a large number of the clones
identified
in your sample whereas with single cell
rna sequencing
even um you know with with modern
techniques with hashtagging
you're only looking at a few thousand
cells at a time so it really does become
a trade-off
of do you really need to know the entire
sequence for
your energy receptor versus do you want
to look at
a large number of cells in a population
for questions of clinical research
where you need to look at lots of
numbers of samples
thermo's approach really does become a
really powerful tool
because you can look at lots of cells
and because of the lower cost
for a lot of our more basic science
types of questions that's where we see
more use of the of the single cell
thank you dr o'connor can you talk more
about
how you would use tcr seek in your
analysis for sarcoidosis disease
progression
specifically in terms of phenotyping
disease course that gets worse
versus gets better
yeah that's that's one of our favorite
questions and it's the one that um that
we think about a lot
so so again with sarcoidosis
it's a disease of unknown ideology and
it's variable disease course
and also we see that a lot in in
autoimmune type or inflammatory type
chronic
diseases so everybody would love to have
some
biomarkers or some handle that within
the immune system that would help us
understand
why there's differential progression or
differential disease phenotypes
and ultimately why disease course looks
so different
so we've been tracking t cells and b
cells
in sarcoidosis through things like rna
sequencing
my lab specifically interested in
epigenetics so we
look at histone modifications by chip
sequencing and through those methods
we've been able to at a bulk population
level
understand some of the molecular
programming that's happening inside of
the cell so
whether a cell is it seems to be
programmed more towards
a th1 type of function or a t17 type of
function
and then we try to relate that to to
what's happening
in terms of disease course but none of
that type of analysis
rnac or chipseek none of that type of
analysis really gives us a handle on
individual clones or individual t cells
and what's happening within the t cell
population and because we know that
a hallmark of adaptive immunity is this
idea of clonal expansion the the
observation that
when an immune response occurs you see
this expansion of a specific clone which
then translates into a specific
unique combination of t cell receptor or
b cell receptor genes
being able to observe that
expansion of those t cell receptor and
bc b cell receptor genes
allows us to understand what's happening
actively in
those two compartments and so what we're
doing now with t-cell receptor and
b-cell receptor sequencing in
sarcoidosis is trying to understand
what is happening in b-cells and t cells
over time and how does that correlate
with some of these differential
molecular programming that we're seeing
so some of the questions we're trying to
ask are do we see
changes in tcr genes being used
essentially are we seeing different
kinds of t-cell clones
associated with different t cell
functions so
are we seeing examples of of clones that
seem to be associated more
with th1 function or more with th17
function
are we seeing specific clones arising
that seem to be associated with
different disease progression and i
think some of the evidence i showed you
today is that
at least early on in very primary
analysis we are seeing
signs that specific clones are
do seem to be associated with with
progressive disease
or at least active disease so the way
that we're thinking about using tcr
is applying it in the context of these
other assays using
acids such as rna-seq or
or chipseek to understand the molecular
underpinnings of the function
that seems to be associated with
worsening disease but then
understanding does that seem to be
associated with specific t cell
populations through this tcr analysis
we're doing something similar with with
b
cells we do see evidence of a specific b
cell function that seems to be
associated with
sarcoidosis and so again we'd like to
understand is that is that
broad across different kinds of b cells
or does it seem to be associated with
specific types of b cells
and that's that's um that's a line of
research that we're just starting to get
into
so we think of tcr and bcr sequencing as
really a nice way to to sort of reach
into the immune
compartment and try to identify specific
activity at an individual clone level
thank you let's go with this next
question what kind of dedicated
bioinformatic resources
do you need to perform this data
analysis
yeah so um i hope that
i hope that i was able to give everyone
the idea that this
this is a really easy system to use um
again i want to say i'm not
trained in bioinformatics or
computational biology and
um all of the data figures or a lot of
them anyway that you saw today i
generated
and that says a lot so we
we have we have really great
bioinformatics resources and
computational
biology researchers here at national
jewish
we have a whole dedicated um facility
for bioinformatics we have a super
computer cluster
on campus so we have really uh really
you know beefy
capability and um you you really don't
need it
um to do this kind of analysis thermo
fisher has provided a really amazing
very intuitive very user-friendly tool
that that is fairly seamless
with with the assay we have
we have done some um tcr sequencing
for individuals outside of national
jewish and have been able to interface
with them through the tool
and they found it very easy to use um
very intuitive
so so really you know if you're a lab
that doesn't have access to lots of
bioinformatic
tools or or individuals and you don't
really know anybody who's
a computational biologist you can still
do this
type of analysis um therma's really
great at providing you a walkthrough
with
the online tools and what's available so
so i really do want to encourage
everybody
if you know if you don't feel
comfortable
in the computational space it's this
that's really not a
barrier to do doing this kind of
analysis
can you compare and contrast the use of
dna
versus dna rna for the assay
yeah um so
so we've had i have to say most of what
we've done thus far has been using rna
as our input and we've had really great
luck
going down to very low amounts of input
and
generally in the context of clinical
research you're taking your samples and
trying to do lots of different things
with them so
it really fits in well in that context
so you know we typically
are taking our samples and trying to
pull off um you know bulk rna-seq
and maybe chip seek and so being able to
not
being able to use a low amount of
material
going into this analysis is is one of
the huge
advantages that we that we find so
that's that's on the rna side
we have had a couple of examples and
again you know i think a really good
example of this
would be somebody who's sitting on a lot
of ffte samples
um those samples tend to be when you
isolate the nucleic acid
tends to be really degraded uh material
and and
you know usually for next gen sequencing
that's that's really difficult to deal
with
the ampliseq system handles um degraded
material really well
again because it's it's this combination
of pcr and
sequencing as the readout so
so it handles that really well and
that's really a context where you'd want
to use dna
and that's what we've done in the past
and again it's worked really well in
those cases
with dna you need more input material
but again you know if you're dealing
with or if you have
ffpe samples usually that's not that's
not a problem
so so those would be two different use
cases i know that
some of the other use cases would be if
you are specifically interested in
in cancer and um you know maybe you're
maybe working on tills tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes and you want to
look at
um at frequencies of different types of
t
cells or maybe you're looking at
hematological malignancies and you want
to look at frequencies
that's really again where you want to
use dna there's really not a great way
to use
rna for for deconvolution of that data
so
there's different use cases that really
i think does come down to what your
what your specific questions are
dr o'connor you talked a little bit
about infection-driven
exacerbation in respiratory disease is
that a big
problem and how could you use ngs-based
approaches to address that issue
yeah really good question so so for a
lot of the diseases that we see in
national jewish these respiratory
diseases
um one of the the huge problems that
that we all face are these exacerbation
periods that lead to
to worsening lung function and a lot of
times
these exacerbations are driven by by
infections
so in the case of cf where
they're really strong robust infections
they're fairly easy to see
quote unquote and so doing tcr bcr
sequencing allows you to see the immune
response so essentially track the
infection by tracking the immune
response to that infection
in other cases we we are dealing with
exacerbations where there's suspected
infection but it's really difficult to
track
and so so that's a case again where
ampliseq works really well
so we um we had a a project that was
funded by um the bill melinda gates
foundation
um looking at mtb tuberculosis
and we were able to use an amplistique
approach
to track the presence of tb
in different samples over a treatment
course
and and we tried to do this with other
typical methods such as 16s
qpcr and really the ampliseq approach
again because it's that combination of
pcr and sequencing
amplified the signal to a point where we
were able to get better resolution or at
least
equal resolution to what we were able to
get with 16 sq bcr
but with the huge advantage that now we
could track lots of different
um gene expressions specific to to tb
which allowed us to ask a lot more
questions about what was happening
to the to the pathogen in the context of
the disease course
so um so there's lots of different you
know the power of ampliseq
and and the approach that you can take
with ngs
to ask questions about how do infections
contribute to
uh to disease and disease course over
time
the resolution you get with ngs is
really opens up a lot of new types of
questions
thank you dr o'connor now we have time
for a few more questions
but i do want to let our audience know
that any questions we are unable to
answer
live today and additionally those that
are submitted during the on-demand
period
they will be addressed via the email
address you provided
at the time of registration so we have
time for a few more
let's go with this one why would someone
choose the short read
versus long read version of the essay
yeah um other good questions we didn't
get a lot of time to talk about it but
yeah there are
there is a short read versus a
long-range version of for both tcr
and vcr sequencing so um the short read
uh version again would be great in a
situation of ffte
where you suspect that you're going to
have a lot of degraded
sample and you're not sure about how
much of the intact
gene you're going to have gene
expression you're going to have
or dna intact dna recombination that
you're going to have so the short read
assay would be a really great
application for that
in contrast if you are a b-cell
immunologist or
if you're dealing with a clinical
research project that
has a b-cell component to it and you're
interested in looking at class switch
recombination
so the isotype switching that's really
where you're going to want to look at
the long read assay because you're going
to get the entire
entire vdj segment plus the constant
region that is type switching
so again you know they're really they're
two nice options to have
and it really does come down to what's
the material that you're working with
what's your question
um how much information you're looking
for if you really just
are trying to track clones um the clonal
expansion
observe them then you probably could get
you know use the short read assay
if you want to understand more about the
immunobiology such as cluster
combination then the long-rate assay is
a really good
option for you
thank you would you be expanding on
how you use different tools to examine
molecular programming of immune cells
in the context of respiratory disease
course
specifically in terms of ngs approaches
such as tcrc
or rnac
yeah so um so you know i think everybody
these days is doing some sort of ngs in
their
in their uh in their research and um
we've been involved in different ngs
essays now for for quite a while
one of the things that we are starting
to understand
is that a lot of these assays really do
feed off of each other so if you do
something like rna-seq and chip seek
we start to think of chip-seq looking at
histone modifications is the programming
and rna-seq is the readout of that
programming through transcription
so those two acids can really feed off
of each other and allow you to ask some
really interesting questions
of immune cells in the context of
different diseases
so tcrc and bcrc you know come along
and add another component to to those
kinds of assays
again we we are using things like
chipseek and rnac
to try to understand the molecular
programming
in the context of chronic diseases over
time in these
in these memory cells but understanding
what's happening to the individual cells
the clonal cells the individual
t cells or b cells that express a unique
b-cell receptor t-cell receptor
gives us another layer on top of
understanding that
that programming because if we see
programming changes in the context
of of a disease course
it'd be great to understand if the t
cell compartment and the diesel
compartment is changing as well
or if it's this the same kind of cells
and they're changing over time those are
these are those gives you two very
different scenarios
and gives us a really powerful way to
start thinking about what's happening to
these chronic diseases
and ways that we might be able to think
about
intervening in those inflammatory
courses you dr o'connor and we have time
for one more question
and i couldn't end this webinar without
touching on the subject
as we all know sars kobe 2 is
overwhelming the research community
currently
how do you think it will affect
immunology and disease research
approaches
and how can we use ngs based approaches
to help study the impact
of the virus
yeah that's a that's obviously a really
poignant question
and you know i think uh thermo
therma has come out with an an
amplistique tool
that allows people to sequence to
sequence
the stars cov2 genome um
tools like tcr pcr sequencing you know
obviously allow you to track the immune
response
so you know i don't think any of us have
a really good sense of
how the presence of the virus in the
context of these chronic diseases what
you know what's going to happen
in terms of disease course but obviously
having these tools being able to
understand how the virus
is changing with an individual through
perhaps sequencing
the viral genome with ample seek or
understanding how the chief of
compartment and peaceful department is
changing
in the context of the presence or
absence of virus obviously
those are enormously helpful tools to
understand
what how are we going to have to change
the way that we think
about the way that we conduct our
research projects um
for for these different diseases um so
just just being able to see
those changes um obviously that's kind
of like the first step and
trying to understand how we how we move
forward
thank you dr o'connor and thank you for
this informative q a session
before we go i do want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
there were quite a few questions we were
unable to get to
and additionally those questions that
come in during the on-demand period
we will make sure that these are
addressed via the email address that you
provide
at the time of registration i would once
again like to thank dr brian o'connor
for his time today
and his important research we'd also
like to thank labruts
and our sponsor thermofisher scientific
for underwriting today's
educational webcast today's webcast can
be viewed on demand
and lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now we hope to see you
again soon
have a great day